until the end of october 2021 there's
the first ever theories of everything
merch at the link in the description or
you can visit tinyurl.com
tow merch t-o-e-m-e-r-c-h
kurt j mungle is a filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
dedicated to the explication of what are
called theories of everything from a
theoretical physics perspective but as
well as outlining the possible
connection consciousness has to the
fundamental laws of nature provided
those laws exist at all and are knowable
to us
kurt jamungal also happens to be myself
as this is and ask me anything that was
recorded live on october 27 2021
thank you and enjoy this ask me anything
with kurt jaimungle
if you can see this type art vandelay
art vandelay
okay if you can see this type itchy and
scratchy
itchy and scratchy
all right
okay
so there are quite a few questions
i think there are approximately
130 or so
so if i seen glib
and or curt
then
well i have to be in order to get
through these
okay
hello everyone thank you hi
so six pool six ix pool asks
kurt which toe is your favorite so far i
like wolfram box take i like wolframs
and box take personally and was curious
what your thoughts are on those in
particular
now for me some people say it's like
choosing babies which one is your
favorite
but that would imply that i have an
attachment to them and they don't have
an attachment to any particular toe it's
more like asking me which renaissance
painting is my favorite i don't know
enough about renaissance paintings in
order to have some favorite
i don't have a criteria to compare them
i don't have some integrated world view
that would necessarily need to be there
in order for me to see the connections
between the two or make some criteria
now for bach i don't understand what he
means precisely by simulation
so i i don't understand
why such a process would entail an
experiential element
for wolfram i understand wolfram wolfram
speaks my language
as for which one's my favorite again i
don't have a i don't have a favorite i
have some that i like and dislike but
it's difficult for me to
disentangle the theory from the person
proposing the theory here's an example i
recently spoke to carla rivelli
i happen to like carla rivelli plenty
because of our relationship once we
spoke same with the mcgill christ so i
know that unconsciously i'll ascribe
them more positive points than i would
if i didn't get along with the person
and i'm extremely careful about making
statements about which toe
which toe i like and dislike because of
that
reason i don't take it lightly
okay mark n says do you now consider
yourself a non-dualist is this a concept
you've worked with for a while
has one of your guests convinced you or
brought you closer to this i'm not a
non-dualist
and i don't think you can claim to be a
non-dualist if you actually were one
because to say it with words implies the
opposite of non-dualism so in either
sense i'm not a non-dualist
sis moan straw
apologies if i don't read your name
correctly sisman asks kurt i subscribe
to your channel immediately after
watching the hoffman episode cool when
are you going to interview hoffman again
whenever he's ready a beer maginder says
hey kurt i want to ask
see some of these questions aren't
written i have a difficult time parsing
parsing what's written if it's not
written
exactly grammatically correctly because
i skim quite quickly and then if it and
then if it doesn't cohere i have to keep
going back to the beginning hey kurt i
want to ask what are researching on or
want to research in the future so kurt i
want to ask what are you researching and
what would you like to research in the
future
how do you research your guest number
two and how long does it take to
research about a guest three what are
your views so there's quite a few
questions here what are your views on
ethics for how do you take biotechnology
okay i'm not gonna answer that five
what are your views on happiness and
well-being
six how do you find peace and chaos and
lastly how do you chill
thanks
for these amazing interviews and your
love for us
well as for researching i just watch
lectures i go through someone's google
scholar page if they're a scholar and i
sort by most cited and then most recent
and i look at a few of those i don't
print them i usually read digitally
i don't have a view on ethics i think
it's
a secular and at times cowardly way of
saying morality without making an appeal
to morality
because people have got a phobia they're
afraid to invoke the usage of god or
objective morality and people like to
appear to be enlightened rational people
or
more specifically they like to not
appear to be
like those backward religious people and
by religious they tend to mean a straw
man of what religious is
okay as for happiness happiness is a
wonderful state it's a wonderful
wondrous state
that's my view on it as for peace and
chaos i don't i luckily don't have much
chaos in my life
i also wouldn't say that i have a great
deal of peace unless i'm with my wife or
i'm driving i like long
drives
alone i enjoy much of my day almost each
minute
except if i have to edit which i so
despise video editing
and they often take half of the day if i
have to more than half of the day for
example leo guru took two days
as for chilling i don't chill much i'm
not a chill person per se if i chill
it's with my
brother we have what we call bro dinners
and those sometimes get philosophical
though in an unfurled manner and i also
enjoy spending time with my wife
i look forward to playing video games
again and i just
man i'm
i am well i used to be such a cheap
cheap cheap person
if i bought a video game i'd play every
i'd scour it i'd play it till the end
get 100
because i paid plenty of money for it
recently however i bought ghosts of
toshima
and i i don't like that game man and i
paid a hundred dollars for it so i'm
gonna have to put it down i see it as an
open world like just the epitome of
open world games now like horizon zero
dawn which i also didn't like
i
i may play hades i downloaded that and i
like that so i'm very much looking
forward to taking a break in november
december and even part of january and
playing some video games and chilling
john d asks question you actively engage
with your fans how do you keep from
being
overloaded by their input
firstly john i consider reading the
comments as part of the work and it's
the joy of the work simultaneously i'm
lucky that 90 of the comments are
extremely thoughtful and effusive i take
criticisms to heart though and i modify
my behavior accordingly hopefully for
the better
to be clear i don't have a
bot that automatically hearts comments i
go through and read each one and at some
point it's already getting to be a bit
overwhelming and at some point i may get
my wife to help out on that
okay if i don't get to your question in
the live chat that's because there are
quite a few questions that i've already
called from people who have commented
in various sources
but grizzwaldgrim live asks will you be
there for us
when the rain starts to fall i don't
know how to answer that kurt ryder wants
to know how did i do in high school
so
high school almost all of school i did
extremely poor in
high school in particular i don't know
how i ended up getting into university
let alone university of toronto
given my grades i was poor in everything
except math and physics and even there i
didn't submit my assignments i despised
doing assignments i can do well on exams
and i luckily had a physics teacher that
said
kurt i don't want to be known as the guy
who failed
i'm not trying to sound egotistical but
he said this i don't want to be known as
the guy who failed the next einstein
because at the time i would ask him
advanced physics questions so luckily
even though i should have got a failing
grade in physics he gave me an 80 or 90
or or what have you
based on the exam alone
and perhaps that's what allowed me to
get into math and physics at u of t
there are some people who asked
questions before the live stream started
i don't have access to those
so if you don't mind you can
ask again
mortarsport asks who is my dream guest
i've consistently said it's donald
hofstetter daniel dennett is also up
there human being what kind of light
bulbs do you use to color the background
let's see these i don't mind i like
answering these behind the scene
podcast questions
so as for a lighting setup i have a
light right here
let's get closer and that serves as a
rim light if you know what if you know a
little bit about cinematography serves
as a rim light i have two lights here
which are
i think they're called sad lamps so they
have the wavelength of the sun this may
be another reason why i have such
extreme sleep problems because when i'm
having a
podcast sometimes it goes on until 9 pm
and what i have right here it's telling
me it's daytime for my subconscious
as for behind me i have
it's an infrared light therapy which i
just turn on or my wife turns on
it bathes the back in red
roy dobson
if you believe what rupert and leo have
told you that you are god wouldn't it be
logical
to investigate and follow that path with
rigor even if it reveals everything you
took to believe is true to be false i
don't know by
i don't i don't believe logic is the way
to truth necessarily unless one modifies
what one means by logic
most of the time when people make a
statement that they think is logical or
rational it's driven by so many
unconscious motivations i think people
have an unconscious motivation to
believe their their god
i think it also may be true depending on
what god means well if one takes god to
be reality you're a part of reality
in what way do you think okay so this
one comes from in dream
aptly named because he asks or he or she
asks in what way do you think we're
living in plato's cave
plato's cave
well
in many ways i'll just leave it at that
in many ways scott larkin asks kurt
thank you for your work i know you're
busy however would you consider
checking out the super suspicious
observers youtube channel looking at the
12
000 year disaster playlist
yes i would consider it as for whether
or not i'll get around to it that's
another question thank you scott
so bc asks having a conversation
how long do you think it would take
chris langan to leave leogara speechless
okay
well to me that'd be like loading a
nintendo game into a ps5 or vice versa
they're just incompatible both in their
philosophies and their
disposition
i think both would leave one another
speechless after
a minute or two minutes
griswold grimm says what would i like to
be doing in five years i'm not sure and
i imagine it's not this my instinct
tells me that this has about three years
left in it when i say this i mean the
toe channel it would be great to
continue to speak to people who i'm
decidedly interested in and interviewing
people for the not for the sake of
interviewing but
because i'm interested in speaking with
them
i see many people who
are podcasters speak to people
just for the sake of bolstering their
podcasts
and i don't i would not like to be like
that
part of the appeal of this channel is
some it's something like breaking bad
where since it's inception there's a
conceivable end goal
it's more like a project than a podcast
and the project is explicating toes
which may have an end date it's also
perhaps the subproject of cultivating
one's own toe perhaps my own or the
communities
and just so you know when i say the
community is what i'm referring to is
the youtube comments but also the
discord and the subreddit
if you would like to go to those the
subreddit is reddit.com slash r slash
theories of everything and then the
discord you'll have to look in the link
for the invite
there's also a hilarious
kerchie mungle memes subreddit and by
the way when i was speaking of criticism
taking criticism seriously i also take
those seriously
because well
when i say seriously i mean
well
you can see if you look at some of them
what i'm referring to
roy dobson says i avoided the question
and i know it
okay let's see so let's go back to the
question
would it be logical to investigate the
pot the path that tells you that you
believe your god i don't know i don't
know roy i just don't know
okay carmeister kurt do you
watch anime or read manga
also please interview tom delong
i used to watch anime but nothing more
than what's on ytv which is a canadian
channel or the cartoon network so dragon
ball z pokemon i think i stopped
watching
anime after
two episodes of beyblades which ruined
it for me
or digimon even
so i don't watch or read berserk for
example or if uh evangelion i believe
or gundam i'm not hardcore and just the
fact that i would consider those to be
hardcore shows you how little i read
anime as for tom delong yes i will speak
to tom delong as for when i don't know
when inside person wants to know am i
going to follow up with
leo gura's invitation to las vegas
and also on a more serious note i take
that to be a serious question though on
a more serious note what is your daily
personal development and spiritual
routine alongside your toe quest
i consider leo to be a close
acquaintance bordering on friend and
when i do meet i imagine it would be a
friendship
as for my spiritual routine
i think it's more like an ever-present
incessant thinking about what is
fundamental
what does fundamental mean what does god
mean how can i be closer to god or the
good
john d asks
where does the inspiration for the
direction of your youtube channel come
from
and please speak on the challenges of
changing direction
so i didn't know what john meant by
changing direction
i thought what he meant was this
originally used to be better left unsaid
this youtube channel used to be called
that
and then i changed it to the theories of
everything channel
so i asked john to follow up john says
for example you changed direction and
began talking about ufos
after that sad party so i don't know
what he means by sad party i also don't
consider the ufo topic to be tangential
to toes i see to be intimately tied
okay crypto wants to know when is frank
yang planning to appear
20 22.
i i had to push that because i was so
and i still am so so stretched
yeah absolutely stretched i can't do it
okay stewart scott wants to know
hey kurt i've got a question for you how
do you deal with your base growing
and this growth inevitably including
extremists and mentally ill people what
one person thinks is extreme to one is
normal to another that's seems obvious
so it's difficult to define
for example as being
is not particularly liking the
vaccination of the entire world
simultaneously an extreme view
is being pro-communism extreme well it
depends on what one means by communism
i'm sure i think people want to point
the finger quickly
and show that one side is fanatical for
various unconscious reasons i have a
whole documentary
dedicated to the subject called better
left unsaid it's no simple feat to
define what's extreme i spent years
thinking about it and i feel like i
barely
scratched the surface on that
i also don't like to think of people as
being curt fans i don't think they
should i don't think they are i think
that if they were true kurt fans quote
unquote they wouldn't conceptualize
themselves
as such because i constantly talk about
questioning which is the opposite of
fandom
following
i also rarely make statements for
someone to follow i mainly ask questions
see i'm a fan of gpt-3 but gpt-3 makes
no statements so there's a difference
between liking the quality of someone's
work and liking them as a person or
having an affinity for their views those
are different
carmeister says you always ask the
audience to refer to dragon ball z
characters in the chat who's your
favorite dragon ball z character it
would be goku or vegeta or gogeta
a miyazaki fan but i don't
i don't think i'm a miyazaki fan because
of the anime per se he just makes great
movies
i would like to visit japan in
particular
because there's a miyazaki museum there
and they also have
apparently wonderful toilets and i'm a
huge germaphobe so part of the reason i
don't travel is because
i can't use toilets and
i can't use other people's toilets
oral decoy wants to know am i over doing
the fasting i haven't fasted in quite
some time
weeks even i was having terrible
terrible terrible sleep issues and so i
had to stop the fasting because i wasn't
interrupting my sleep that's a hilarious
question the signal if you could fusion
dance with any person in a dragon ball z
man or who would it be
i don't it would
be my wife then or no one unless there's
the novelty of doing it with someone
temporarily if it's permanent i don't
think i'd do it okay kurt i am mr nimbus
what do you think is going on at
skinwalker ranch and what experiment
would you like to see do you hope aliens
made us
or not
what is the thing or who is the one that
convinced you aliens are real
okay so firstly who the heck knows
what's happening in skinwalker
as for
whether or not i hope i hope not that
they made us but at the same time i
think it's a sin to think that the
universe isn't the way that it's
supposed to be so
whichever way it turns out to be i think
i should be grateful for life third i
never said aliens are real mr nimbus
says by the way i would love to buy some
cool alien merch
just so you know this isn't a ufo
channel despite the popularity of the
ufo videos
it's a theoretical physics consciousness
free will and god channel and if ufos
turn out to be
let's say purely artificial intelligence
then someone like lex will handle it for
now i see it as a physics and
potentially metaphysics related
phenomenon hence my investigation of it
it's also darn curious man
as for the merch just so you know you
can go to
tinyurl.com tow merch i believe i'll
type that in the chat and there's merch
not ufo themed there's merch for the
next few days it's ending october 31st
john d again john d can you put a finger
on how many times you felt your mind
finally grasp a new concept
or does that happen to you more on a
daily basis it happens sometimes zero
times per day sometimes multiple times
per day i would say it's more accurate
to think of
my mind as recontextualizing thoughts
and adding layers like
those of you who know a little bit about
computer graphics you start with some
unspecified sphere and then you add some
elements like a reflective map and a
texture and an extrusion albedo asparty
the shape of the surface its properties
under destruction or collision and so on
so for me it's as if each toe
or concept is blank
it's a blank metal ball with disparity
with roughness equals zero
and then as days go by i add more and
more layers to it until
hopefully i can say
the toe back to the originator of the
toe in a manner that they would agree
perhaps it'd be better if i can even add
to it
einstein alberto those toe socks seem
pretty meta and i'm digging it okay well
again if you'd like you can go to the
merch link tinyurl.com
toe merch those are available for the
next few days frank boyle says congrats
my friend on
a very well deserved 100k
my question is
my favorite inter my question in my
favorite interview which was rupert
spyra
i was intrigued by the depth of your
honesty
and could feel an almost existential
level of anxiety when you discussed your
darker thoughts and and fear
and how you could act irrationally on
impulse and so on
there was a sense there was a sense that
i was viewing carl jung's concept of the
shadow being played out in real time
well that's embarrassing
so i the guy says i wonder if
frankie says i wonder if you could
elaborate on your
on your personal beliefs
for the raison d'etre by your guests in
short
what has impacted your way of thinking
in a profound way
i started this podcast i started taking
this podcast seriously with donald
hoffman
in terms of delving into someone's
papers deeply and then with thomas
campbell i started taking it extremely
seriously experientially
like i tried transcendental meditation
for a few weeks and i think perhaps even
months
taking toe seriously has impacted my
thinking
though i wouldn't
rather than one tone in particular
well i don't know maybe it would be ian
mcgill chris bernardo castro
or raymond smalley and that's my
favorite video on the whole channel it's
underrated it has less than ten thousand
views and it's my favorite video i think
you should watch that the raymond
smalling video
it's a mirthful dialogue between
immortal and god about free will
and morality proceedloter asks congrats
kurt my question is this what arguments
and positions from the left do you find
strongest and most convincing to you
so i did a quick google search because
it's not clear what makes the left left
for example if you ask people on the
left they'll say my site is good and i
am pro freedom but people on the right
would say the same
as for left when i did a quick search i
like separation the separation of church
and state
i think that's a left-wing view though
that's that's i'm sure debatable
i like when there's investment into city
parks and beautifying the city in
general
i like when there's a net to catch the
indigent the destitute the panurius
jaywartman1984 says
i just subscribed today because i
thought i already was okay
i couldn't find you in my list haha
great show bravo
what do you think about travis walton's
testimony
some of these questions are quite large
and so i'm trying to parse them
make them concise
okay what what do you think a trained
body language expert would say of lou
wearing the hat that obstructs his face
when answering questions what do you
think about that i like blue but felt
the hat was disingenuous even deceptive
he was in counter intel after all and
understands body language
see for me i think
if he was in counterintelligence he
would not wear a hat precisely because
one wants to give the impression that
one is being open
he would have been taught to speak with
his palms out constantly
and the fact that he's not suave to me
is indicative of him not being
instructed to act in a manner that's
convincing and amiable the hat seems to
me to be more of a comfort item like
that he's dealing with a heavy load
which is understandable i've spoken to
people who have made a living
having an extremely high eq if eq exists
having an extremely high ability to read
someone's body language and when i say
that they make a living in it i mean
that they're not simply body language
experts or people who give seminars as
such but people who make money
analyzing other people and they've said
they've expressed a similar sentiment
with regard to lou
namely that he's under stress and he
isn't speaking with
perfidy or duplicity
just a regular guy with an anime profile
picture asks
how would you rank the following four
and why superman thor hulk and goku so
goes goku superman
thor and hulk
i don't know who likes hulk man
the signal wants to know do you have
advice for building a successful channel
for aspiring podcasters or youtubers for
aspiring youtubers i don't consider
myself to be a youtuber i don't think
i've ever said subscribe man hit that
notification bell
smash that like button
i don't think i've ever said that i feel
extremely
well i don't i wouldn't like to say that
as for podcasting
watch each one of your own episodes
colin quinn my favorite comedian was
asked how do you get better at stand up
so seinfeld's advice is work just work
colin quinn's advice is tape every show
and watch it
i agree with colin quinn and seinfeld by
the way
okay freedom fighter how many licks does
it take to get to the center of a
tootsie pop well you can just look that
up i did a quick google search and it's
approximately how many days there are in
a year i couldn't think of some profound
answer to that question
giovanni peasant says not a question but
rather a request can you do a recap on
how your view of god life and the
universe and everything has evolved
and what are your key life experiences i
don't think i can do that man
danger six
says may you please acknowledge that you
have seen my super chat i don't know
danger 6 i have to now search for which
okay i'm searching
nope i don't see it
okay but i see scott larkin scott larkin
says have you tried cava cava for sleep
and anxiety if not you should
traditional preparation method only
avoid the extracts
i haven't tried that
ryan p asks have you revisited
tmu
no i have not
rob
warnick asks what do you believe you a
fee uaps are
have you heard theories about the
antichrist
and such no
i mean yes i've heard those theories i
don't know what they are
i imagine that if here's what i imagine
they're not
i don't think they're purely
atmospheric phenomenon or lens flares
and so on
i think that if one had a rock and threw
it at an a at a uap or ufo it would make
a sound provided that the ufo would
allow it to hit it
sorry danger six you're gonna have to
repeat vincent thank you
tom assuming that bob lazar's story is
true and pairing it with leo's louis
elisondo's idea that the us is in
possession of materials how do we know
the crafts military members
i don't understand the question tom i'm
sorry
oh oh oh
tom if what you're asking is let's
imagine there have been some recovered
craft how do we know that what we're
seeing isn't
our craft
that is repurposed craft could be
though david fravor says extremely
unlikely given that they appear on
battlefields and if the us wants to win
a war
or have some military objective you
wouldn't unduly scare the pilots right
before a military operation or during a
military operation
danger 6 says
i have some evidence that suggests these
beings may control people by terrorizing
them in youth then providing meaningful
help in adulthood trauma bonds that's
extremely interesting so danger six if
you have a link dm me at tow with kurt
on twitter and i'll include that link in
the description
marinka s says dude just appreciate you
man question is pretty much only one how
do you manage work-life balance
firstly i don't manage it well and
that's one of the reasons i'm taking
november december and perhaps even
january off as an extended respite to
breathe with my wife and with my family
austin harper
says
my question for you kurt is future
humans will be born in artificial wombs
and gene edited to basically eradicate
any chromosomal disease or genetic
disease of any kind
second if it's possible are my parents
and other loved ones actually any
different than a stranger on the road
should i treat them as different or
should i treat
other strangers like my brother and
sister
okay
so it seems like
it will be the case in the near future
that people will be
devoid of genetic flaws quote unquote
but i think in the long run it will be
that
we may
allow what we currently consider to be
quote unquote flaws to occur naturally
because we have a better understanding
firstly of what it means to be natural
as well as
we see that there's a reason for people
to be
the way they are and when they say a
better understanding of what it means to
be natural right now we say whatever we
do is unnatural
so is it well
aren't we a product of nature so is our
gmos particularly unnatural is this
condo unnatural is internet on that the
internet unnatural i don't know it
seemed well we're a part of nature
but from other
vantage points i see that it's
considered to be unnatural all of that
is to say that i imagine we'll have a
more refined notion of what it means to
be natural
as for should you treat
the people you see on the street like
your brother and your sister in terms of
love i don't think it's possible
but i also think that one should
cultivate a stronger relationship with
their family
so that is raise the level of love with
your family and raise the level of your
love for your stranger such that today's
average love for your family is six
months from now
average love for the stranger and then
by then your average love for your
family has increased so you use that as
a slingshot to also
increase the average love you have for
people in general
michael frey have you seen any
significant patterns
in all the incoming information that
points you to a particular direction i'm
not sure if that's with regard to the
ufo
issue or toes in general and i see
similarities yes and i see differences
more similarities though
the dark knight or the dark light
there appears to be an instrument
hanging in front hanging on the wall
behind you
do you play music or have any other
creative outlets
what music do you listen to
i don't listen to music
i find it extremely irritating i find
most music extremely extremely
irritating i used to play songs i used
to play cover songs and minorly create
my own but since i've moved in here i
haven't played
almost at all because i sing when i play
and i sing so loud these walls are paper
thin i can't can't practice i don't have
the time anyway
as for other creative outlets i can't
think of any
hmm
i don't think so
i put almost everything into
studying toes
theories of everything
searing wants to know are you
continually studying the ctmu and how
does it rank among the other towels
you've looked into so i'm diminutively
studying it and it's high up there in
terms of the theories of everything i've
studied
philip oh and
caveat i don't particularly like to rank
them when i say hi up there
i do have a
a nesting though i wouldn't call that
evaluation that's different
philip o
on a spectrum from bach to castro
where were you before starting this
podcast and where are you now i would
say i was full-on bach in the
materialist sense and now torn in the
middle watching mommy and daddy fight
sullen piffin or sullen puffin that's a
hilarious name
the sullen puffin asks how quickly can
you get
castor up and bach head to head
bach is not interested
castro would but bach is not interested
um okay henrik
lance hedstrom has a question about
it's a quite a long question
and they
he essentially wants to know about time
travel so for me time travel is filled
with so many paradoxes that i don't know
how to conceive of it but just because i
can't conceive of it doesn't mean that
it's not describing some situation
that's true in some non-trivial sense i
just don't know how to make sense of it
you can understand this like carlo
ravalli has a great
example of this if you read some ancient
texts
i'll get into that in the carla ravilli
podcast so i'm not going to speak about
that now
imagine yellow suns wants to know would
you would you consider the topic of
near-death experiences for your
investigations and interviews yes and i
have dean raiden confirmed though not
booked for 2022 i have many guests
confirmed when i say confirmed i mean
they've said yes and i've said yes but
as for getting the actual date down
that's an arduous task lord tyrones did
i find chris langan to be intimidating
not particularly
okay i'm scrolling through now so give
me some time as i go through the live
chat
d v n malwat says great job on the last
couple interviews kurt just watched the
one with travis i wish you had gone into
more details you know what divin
when i went into details with travis
people took that as a sign of me
interrogating him
and they thought that i was being
well
mean to him
i did find travis well there was
something that occurred directly before
the travis interview
i was irritated during it that was the
only interview that i was irritated
just prior to conducting
for a couple of reasons
i don't want to go into them without
i think it would sound like i'm bashing
travis has nothing to do with travis's
experience and more has to do with
him as a person but not his experiences
as for his experiences i don't treat
people skeptically on this channel i
treat people as if what they're saying
is true and i'm curious what the
consequences are
and
am i understanding it correctly it's
pretty much just that what are the
consequences am i understanding it
correctly can i add to it does it
contradict anything that i currently
know
office hours i've said this many times i
treat it like i have a professor
and i'm
blessed enough to have office hours with
this person so i don't go into a
professor's office hours being skeptical
of the person i treat them as if they're
superior to me at least in some ways
daniel jake jacobian says thank you for
the journey you've decided to take thank
you daniel scott are you familiar with
episode of coast to coast in 97 no i'm
not familiar with that
robin robinson thoughts on einstein's
theory of non-empty space and gravity as
a pressure force caused by displacement
of dark matter i don't think einstein
had a
theory of dark matter i don't think it
was discovered
any time around when einstein was alive
and i don't know of his theory of
non-empty space
if you mean dark energy that's different
okay brandon carroll says have you or
christopher langan considered a stream
with jean francois
garappy now i don't know what
christopher lennon has considered so i
can't speak for him
i have not considered a stream with gene
i don't know who gene is there are
plenty of times when people will message
in the comments and say you should check
out so-and-so person my process is i
mentally note them first and then once i
see enough of them
then i start to
physically note them and then i
contact them
and then well i research them and then i
contact them
abedi debato wants to know how did you
quit your mathematical career well
firstly i never had a mathematical
career
i
stopped math and physics when i went
into filmmaking but even if you watch my
films there's such a heavy framework of
math and physics the same analytical
mind i apply to the film i apply to the
film story and to the filmmaking and
i've always been interested in theories
of everything almost as long as i can
remember
when i say as long as i can remember i
mean
since i was a kid
since i first thought about well how did
the universe come to be and learned of
the concept of quantum fluctuations
pseudohumans says what toe of all the
guests do you resonate with most i think
is most valid i would say chomsky and
i'll leave that as a
i'll leave that for you to interpret
what that means from start to free gary
sigman asks
kurt you should try to get naseem
haramin on for an interview
okay by the way
people who ask to be interviewed is
generally not a great sign that you have
to be asked for example if someone says
i can disprove leo what glio guru is
saying and thus i should be interviewed
that's not enough for me to interview
you just because you have a critique of
someone
i'm interested in constructions and
entire world views that are different
well i use instinct and intuition to
guide me
it's just it's not enough for someone to
say you should interview me
and people get extremely offended
extremely offended when i don't have the
time to look into their theories or have
them on the channel and part of the
reason is i take each theory of
everything extremely seriously i
i take them extremely seriously so i
don't have time
and every single almost each person will
say my theory of everything is the
theory of everything to end all theories
of everything okay how do i adjudicate
between the different people putting
their hands up that say the same
sentiment
g
bernal wants to know apparently we had
an email exchange exchange and this
person wants to know
what do i think of the ufo topic
essentially it's a long question but
essentially what do i think of it and
it's unfair to ask me that
because i didn't know how vast this
topic would be when i
entered it think of it like i thought it
was one painting and it turns out that
it's an art gallery and now i've been
zoomed along in the louvre and you're
asking me what do you think of the
louvre well i see patterns that's all i
can make of it for now i can't rank them
john d again john d many questions
when you do need to increase your staff
i do already
i would like to get someone to do video
editing for example or the toe clippings
channel when you do increase your staff
will you advertise toe jobs now this is
hilarious
i may i don't i'm not sure
prathema nagendra wants to know what a
guy what a channel more power to you you
haven't invited any hardcore biologists
and i'm going to put slash materialist
because many people have said that on
your channel
that's not true that's not true people
say that that's
there's bach first of all there's
rebecca goldstein
stephen wolfram robert kuhn though he
wouldn't admit that he's a materialist
richard borchards methune david sloane
wilson anil seth
sabine haasenfelder stephen pinker
nathan mirvald
avi loeb i believe is a materialist
kevin knuth i'm not sure but maybe
michael evan maybe chomsky somewhat carl
frisbin somewhat drawer barnette
definitely most
not most many people
are adamant atheist materialist hardcore
biological basis for consciousness
and they'll say
they'll
well
i'll leave it at that mel taylor
my son is studying physics math and
computer science a level
would you recommend physics as a degree
no unless you want your your son to live
with you until you're until they're 40.
i would recommend computer science beers
attitude
what are the most interesting
fascinating ideas to you right now in
relation to your channel of course
not free will not toe not god but some
new idea that you've read about heard
from your guests something from physics
perhaps
maybe something about ufos maybe
something political that got you really
thinking
what are you hyped about right now
um what am i hyped what am i hyped about
hyped about
i think i am hyped about something
as for what
the lowenheim scolam theorem
and the nature of infinity
when i was talking to leo gura
he
made it clear that he believes the
infinity of all infinities is reality
now that's not look
kantor even thought that but even but
leo would say that's a model of infinity
and so on however when leo was
delineating what he believes infinity to
be imagine a movie and now imagine a cup
now imagine a movie about a cup now
imagine a movie about a cup making a
movie about a cup and so on and so on
and so on i don't think he realizes
how
embedded in aleph zero that is
what i mean is that's all still aleph
zero that's all still the natural
numbers he thinks
what he was outlining was aleph one or
lf2 there are different levels of
infinity but those are all if you can
point to it
it's part of the natural numbers
the natural numbers are a huge huge huge
huge huge huge set in other words
gerald pavlovich says you often expect
or say that you expect the next paradigm
shift to come from the fringe and i'm
wondering could you elaborate on your
definition of fringe and why you believe
this spirituality slash physics of
consciousness merger will or must
which i yes will or must
come from the outside
and what
are those groups you consider to be
fringe
so firstly einstein worked in the patent
office keep that in mind that's fringe
in some respects
but i'm sure that's not what you mean
nor what i mean
i mean
mainly that the fringe will be
that
i i do think it will be someone or some
people from the center let's say not
fringe that
take that torch past the goal post i
think they'll be
heavily
informed
and advised and apprised by the fringe
but the reason i say will come from the
center too is because the fringe doesn't
necessarily have the technical know-how
of how to make their statements precise
or how it comports and doesn't comport
with other
theories for example most of the time
when
almost any time when someone mentions
quantum physics it's an indication to me
they don't know what they're talking
they don't they generally don't know
what they're talking about and you'll
see this even brian keating said this
people will email him say einstein was
wrong it's rarely boltzmann was wrong
and the reason is that
people read what they read in popular
science now there's an advantage to that
well the disadvantage what i think i
think people should stop trying to sound
astute and tutored and just be
and that one's gift may be that they're
that they're not particularly astute in
those domains and because of that
they're able to make these wide reaching
jumps that someone who is not untutored
they could never make those jumps
for example for me when it comes to
filmmaking i'm so
engrossed in filmmaking or i was that a
new filmmaker can innovate far more than
i can because certain shots wouldn't
occur to me certain editing techniques i
would dismiss unconsciously before it's
even reached my conscious mind as being
something that wouldn't work
that's an example so it's okay to not be
particularly precise that's why i say
that the fringe will inform the center
and the center will be the one that
takes it past the goal
but the center won't be able to do so
without the fringe so they both need one
another
and they both should stop deriding one
another
so someone james don't this is hilarious
so sir roger penrose was on the joe
rogan podcast talking about the
emperor's new clothes i think he means
new mind after a retired
anesthesiologist contacted him to tell
him about microtubules and so on do you
think that you can talk about this on
your podcast
microtubules and such have you heard of
it okay so this happens so frequently
that someone will say have you heard of
this someone said have you heard of
thomas campbell you should speak with
him man i have two podcasts with thomas
campbell
so i don't know what to do with that
i'm i can't expect everyone to just
search the catalogue of toe before
asking a question it's just funny to me
because then i have to find the url and
have some hotkeys for the most popular
videos and i just send that to them
i think it'd be snarky if i said
google is your friend search
danger six you said that you can't tell
me or tell people publicly well then dm
me on twitter
ian from scotland says am i familiar
with phil snyder
no
samwell wants to know what are my views
on remote viewing i don't have many
views on remote viewing i think it's
possible i don't see why not
i there's so much that
is traditionally thought of as
obviously insensate that i don't see as
obviously in sensei
lucid dreaming well elusive dreaming is
great i
i happen to be lucky enough that i can
lose a dream
altered states of consciousness through
meditation or psychedelics well what are
my thoughts in them i don't i don't
one of my
they're powerful states that can
radically change your world view that's
what i think of them
someone wants to know can i get bob
lazar on the show i'm trying to get bob
lazar on the show it's not going to
happen it seems like it's not going to
happen someone wants to know is clee
irwin of quantum gravity research fringe
david wants to know that
to some people he is
i haven't researched him enough to make
a decision he seems extremely
mathematically sophisticated so i
wouldn't consider him to be as such alex
nadel q asks i'm interested in some of
the books you found useful in developing
your
interviewing skills did you develop on
the job or do you have some
recommendations i don't i i don't see
myself as having interview skills when
people say i have an interview style
i'm
non-plussed i don't know what to make of
that because i just see myself as asking
questions i just see myself as again
treating someone
as if they're a professor during office
hours it's as simple as that and that's
pretty much it i don't know about
interview skills per se
hmm
mds wants to know have you asked
if these ufo crafts are living organisms
i think i have i don't know
roman stepping off wants to know what
would you want to happen to your
consciousness after death well it
depends on what
what death is
so if death is the ceasing of
consciousness then that question as it
stands makes little sense or is
contradictory which doesn't mean it's
not worth investigating
i think it would be great if we lived
forever and we're happy
i think i think that's pretty clear
okay someone said what happened so sadia
adani said what happened to the last
video with luis elisando we saw it live
and then it became private okay so
because of that i'm going to
read to you some of my thoughts
i generally make these live streams
private after i've live streamed because
they treat them like a sports event or
any like a play let's say if you come
halfway through the play you miss half
of the play you don't get to see the
first part or if you do then you're to
miss the latter half
you have to catch it from the beginning
to the end just like you would in real
life i treat it as if it's real life
which is different than
youtube like youtube doesn't have a term
for that i wish youtube had a different
word that i could use
like a different setting to indicate
that this is that type of event
if you miss it live you miss it live and
you have to then wait for the dvd
edition you have to wait for it to be
edited there's a reason why i edit it
hmm
see people who for example everyone here
watching live
they can deal with my long pauses and my
incoherent ramblings
but when you watch it for most people
now some people will object and say no
no i like that i love watch i love joe
rogan just because of that okay well i'm
not at joe rogan's level i'm actually an
extremely small creator relatively so so
i use
some of the filmmaking
skills that i've
gleaned over the years to
make it a better pristine product each
podcast i put out is like a gem
each one is like a pristine gem
i try to make it like that one of the
ways is with well
the audio that comes through here via
zoom is compressed people don't realize
how much audio matters for the end
product for example in films audio
matters much more than the visual
experience
okay so there's that i need to change it
for posterity for people who watch it
after when you're watching it live you
have the added exhilaration of this
extemporaneous factor there's a thrill
but it's it's not a great experience for
those who come
later i've written this down
on the subreddit reddit.com slash r
slash theories of everything
also
i tend to put out the video fairly soon
so it shouldn't be too much of a
big deal for people 24 hours to 48 hours
later
there's also conversations that happen
between me and a guest off here before i
ever go live and then often after i end
going live
such as well
there are plenty of examples of that and
i include some of that with the person's
permission
that won't be there and then also people
tend to share the live stream let's
imagine i unlisted people will then
share the unlisted live stream not every
hit but almost each hit matters
for a small creator like myself so when
someone shares the live stream which
i've heard some people saying are we
gonna have to record this now if people
start recording them then i'm gonna have
to just keep the conversations off air
because people will share that that will
get popular and then people won't come
to the tow channel or associate it with
the
so
so that's the reason i put them as
private
there's other reasons
plenty of other reasons too
when someone says which guests theories
are most aligned with mines i'd say
chomsky and again i'll leave that for
you to interpret
vincent weaver says kurt my phone dies
and i may have missed my question
answered i did two super chats two super
chats about avilova i can't find the man
so
say it to me again
and make sure you act me so that it
shows up more blatantly art meditation
says hey kurt thanks for your
contribution is there going to be a part
three with leo guerra maybe
maybe quite some time from now man that
leo video took
i was dealing with so much
at the time so much
and i still
well i was dealing with quite a bit
and i still put out that video and so
because of that that knocked me out for
a while for a little while and turned me
off of not interviewing not speaking
with leo but turned me off of doing a
pristine podcast with leo because it
takes so much work
in the editing mainly mainly the editing
natalie wants to know do i know about
balaji that's the future i don't know
about bolaji
walker dale says after speaking with leo
what did you get reading between the
lines of what he said huh that is that
is for me to keep to myself for now i
don't like to say my thoughts as they're
unformed
i think wittgenstein had this quote
about what one cannot speak of precisely
one must be silent
now there are obviously flaws with that
but generally i stick by that
lance weda says why do you believe in
god any evidence so
firstly
i asked
who said i believe in god and what
definition of god is this person
referring to when asking for my belief
in it slash him slash her slash whatever
lance replied i could be mistaken
but
on the interview with lestrade you
implied the existence of a god i don't
think i did if i did please send it to
me
then this person said my apologies if i
was wrong if so i'd like to re-ask what
are your thoughts on the idea of god so
i don't know i don't know what some see
most people have the idea of god that
something akin to a disembodied powerful
human
who created the earth in the same way
that we create chairs and tables and i'm
unsure if it's like that
rahul asks kurt are you indian i am from
trinidad trinidad and tobago
someone asked if i was sri lankan no i'm
from trinidad khalsa nostra blonde says
i subbed for your joshua bach interview
could you elaborate on what it's like to
be what it was like talking with him
from your perspective
and do you have any takeaways from that
episode
talking with him was like talking with
anyone else there wasn't
there was no ah factor particular to him
as for takeaways see i don't remember
much
much of all of my podcasts are blurs
it's like
when you do an exam and it's a blur
which is why i need a break
it's not for example it's not enough to
read the bible one needs to meditate on
it it's not enough to read some text one
needs to meditate on it
i need to meditate on what i've studied
and i haven't
been okay boris martens
boris costello congrats dude you are
going to the moon for sure thanks man
i feel like i'm on the moon already
though
like
when people say you're going to get a
certain amount of subs i i tend to
i'm ambivalent about hearting those
comments i don't particularly care about
those about having
more subscribers than i do i like
the quote i like the quality of the
subscribers that currently the tow
channel has
and
and if it can continue like this then
that's like i'm
i'm so hap almost each day every single
day
i'm excited for the work that i get to
do it's like a absolute blessing okay
what is your favorite movie of all time
boris asks
not the top three or top five just one
shoot
boris i don't have a i don't have a just
well okay if it was just one it's there
will be blood
and then if it's a top three it's there
will be blood no country for old men and
it's connected in new york
and those are somewhat tied for number
two it's connected to new york and there
will
and no country for all men there will be
blood as holds a special place in my
heart all those were
i think released within months of one
another
there have been
other films i've i've loved dearly call
me by your name is a wonderful
wonderful film
those three though there will be blood
disconnected in new york and no country
for old men are king
richard brewster you've mentioned the
possibility of writing a book about toes
theories of everything
can you say something about how you will
come at this big topic
will you try to be objective by
describing and comparing some of the
selected toes will you write about how
your interviews with the scientists
slash mystics and
so on have impacted you personally i
don't think i'll write that in the book
again i'm not particular i don't
particularly like
talking
i'm much more comfortable asking
questions than i am
answering questions
someone said i think you could pull a
lot together in such a book and i would
sure i would surely buy it so that's
richard brewster so as for the objective
question will i be objective i don't use
the word objective to describe anything
i do nor anything anyone else does
well what i would like to do would be a
conspectus of toes that is to write a
book with a page or two or three or four
depending on each toe in a manner that
the originator of the toe would say sure
that sounds about right
roy dobson says congratulations on your
success you deserve it do you find that
personally you're getting closer to a
toe and two do you think
discovering a toe how do you think
discovering a toe would affect your
subjective experience i gave this
analogy before with the swimmer who's
underwater let me i don't know if i can
remember it precisely
it's as if i have a flashlight and i can
see a certain distance above me and i
hope that i'm swimming upwards and i
have a
an estimate as to how
far i have to go to reach the surface
and while i'm swimming upward
the flashlight increases but so does my
estimate as to how much work is left
increases and as for how do i think
discovering a toe would change my
subjective experience i think it would
be transformative
in the positive sense though i'd say i'm
too cowardly to accept it in any form it
may take
the law of one says love your channel
brother what do you personally think
happens after we die
i don't think it's lights out like a
computer
i don't think it's the afterlife we
think
about either it may be
maybe both in some manner i'm not averse
to
paradoxical contradictory
deliberation
especially on topics that people would
consider to be deep
because most of what we consider to be
deep is metaphysical and most of what's
metaphysical is not defined
precisely and thus
as we talk about it is going to be
contradictory
prashanti dota says thank you kurt
i'm curious how you prepare for these
interviews
i think i said that before it pretty
much
look up lectures on the person
i watch some of their other interviews
i
go to their google scholar page sort by
most cited and sort by most recent and
look at the
top view if they have textbooks or
well if they're an academic they'll have
textbooks i may skim those
if they have books then i'll try to read
them pretty much just that and then i
write down whatever questions occurred
to me that's it i just write them down
whatever questions occur to me and i'm
doing this over the course of a week or
two weeks
and i constantly say i can't say right
now because this will go off i say okay
google
all right so i say that
and then i say note to self and so on
steve sanders says kurt two questions i
haven't heard that are bugging me is the
movie industry preparing humanity for
disclosure
through science fiction movies
a sort of soft slow disclosure
no i think
why we see science fiction movies is
indicative that the public is craving
content like this or
content on topics
about this you can view it in a union
sense
that the collective expresses some
unconscious desire the market will
express some unconscious desire of
people
i also think you're giving hollywood far
too much credit they're just avaricious
they care about dollar amount
the only morality is ostensible morality
when it comes to hollywood
they
have no long-term plan for disclosure
they don't care about the public being
informed other than being informed for
something of their own construction that
aids their bottom line they're
acquisitive they don't care about by
diversity for example as as much as they
say they care about diversity i have
some stories about that which i don't
need to get into but it's just hilarious
that they'll say that they care so much
about diversity it's hilarious to me
they don't they just care that
they would be criticized if they don't
pretend that they do
okay so fettuccine split i think that's
how you say it asks what would your last
meal be no limits
okay let's think about this
it would be any meal firstly i wouldn't
be hungry
and it would be any meal with my wife
that's it
whatever is with my wife
okay that's not terribly uplifting
let's see
how do you manage david smail says how
do you manage to consistently attract
the caliber of guests you have on your
show do you have a script yes i do have
a script and i can send it to you
personally david
just message me
and
i'll start with you now with other
people and the script has changed now
it's now i don't need to have a script i
can just send someone a one-liner and
say hey check out the tell podcast would
you like to be interviewed on it
now because it
it has the following that it does i be a
bit more insouciant with the
construction of the email
and mostly it's a luck it's a profusion
of luck
profusely
someone matt said how do we how should
we treat people like neil degrasse tyson
and others who think
this name namely
what we consider to be paranormal and
pseudoscience and so on who think
that this is all bs are they beholden
are they ignorant paid not to speak
can we trust what they're saying
i think that we should treat them with
love like everyone else
i think that it's easy for us to say to
them you're in sense8 and asinine and
you call yourself a skeptic but you
don't do x y and z like a skeptic should
yeah do that and see how far it takes
you
what is the goal is the goal to win
this this transient dialogue and
sacrifice the greater battle
well
in some ways that's how we got here
with the skeptics deriding
you or us other people
being condescending i advocate not for
and i don't i wouldn't say advocate but
i
i wouldn't say treat people with respect
i'd say
treat them with consideration and love
and warmth
ask them questions
and don't do so in a patronizing manner
now respond with humility because maybe
they are correct maybe there's nothing
to this ufo phenomenon
maybe there's nothing to any of
of
psychic phenomenon and remote viewing
and so on and life after death and maybe
it's true that
we're just a collection of atoms that
somehow via some buckingham mechanism
produce consciousness that could all be
true
who knows
so approach them
as if you're trying to find the truth in
what they're saying even if they're
dislogistic to you
treat them sincerely and warmly
so too honest but true says why can't
kurt just talk he chooses his words so
wisely it's annoying
on a good note happy to have someone
like him interested in ufo we need more
minds like him okay so that's a twin
compliment and insult in some manner
well
like i mentioned it's a combination of
nervousness
and also
determining what i think is not easy
people think well people see part
part of the problem or part of our
problem
in society is people say what
sounds
intellectual or sounds impressive in
some manner and they don't think they
don't realize that what they've said has
been adopted from someone else there's
also a war of options happening in me so
maybe there's three things i could say
and then i see critiques with each or
critiques with one or two of them and
then i'm
so i'm
i'm choosing between what to say i'm
also then
doing some comparison between what i
potentially could say and how i feel and
does that match because what's presented
to me by my unconscious is not always
what i think but just what's a reflex
that's almost the definition of reflex
it's a terribly confounding act to think
for myself
james curtis says i wonder how much you
sleep i don't think you stopped sleeping
i actually got an aura ring because of
this
and it tells me consistently that
i'm not getting restful sleep like i
haven't had a restful night of sleep in
since i got the device
i can get
rem sleep and deep sleep but my
restfulness score is always so low
chris salazar what are your thoughts on
penrose's conformal cyclic cosmology
right
i need to research it that's what i
think about it
hamid halau about iq i think i answered
that in my last ama
chris salazar is wrought is roger
penrose
difficult to get as a guest yes
titi kaizugu asks what are your thoughts
on ken wilbur's spiral
dynamics
i i'm not a fan of spiral dynamics
i just think it's
yeah i'm not a fan of spiral dynamics
though i need to look more into it
a123 thank you
tom says what new info did you get out
of the luis elisando interview does he
seem like he's more willing to reveal
more info or is it just the amazing
questions
i wish i could say
my thoughts about
about that i would just say there's a
method to the madness between
luis elisondo and myself in terms of
questions and answers
andrew j says my toe mug arrived today
great so if anyone has
some toe merch just tweet it at me i
would like to include some pictures of
them
by the way everyone who's watching you
should check out the 100 000 video i'll
link it here that along with the raymond
smalian video is got to be my
favorite video and that was put together
by
a redditor named not my account who also
runs the
reddit account
called i mean there's a subreddit called
kurt german gold memes
which i'll link there okay so hamad
wants to know what do i think of string
theory that's another example when i say
people will say einstein is clearly
wrong and people are trying to sound
um
shrewd in some manner
they
and they'll parrot what they've been
heard what they've heard they'll say
string theory is unfalsifiable well
like you don't know like i'm studying
string theory and it's how do you get to
the stage where you can even say that
it's unfalsifiable string theory has had
implications in condensed matter physics
for example
so it's not as if it's not salutary for
physics as a whole
people will just say
what they've heard
that's what i mean by it's people it's
difficult to think for oneself
natalie says how much money do i need to
spend on a super chat to get you to look
up the 1929 project when you get off
this stream
balaji is kind of an oracle
i don't know but i mean
i'll look it up
for zero dollars i'll try
kundalini kurt can we have more theo
locations i'm trying to i'm trying to
find it's actually difficult to find
what fits with the channel
i'm looking to have two mathematicians
debate the nature of infinity i think
that's going to be so wonderful so the
nature of
the zfc set theory but the nature of
infinity is tied to that because of the
sea the axiom of choice
and what computational logic versus
i forget what intuitionist logic versus
classical logic i believe
johnny cash says i'm always happy to
watch your videos informative helpful
and meaningful discourse thank you man
thank you
ryan betts if you could pick one piece
of knowledge to be answered and you know
for certainty it's reality what would
you pick
ah
that's a that's a tough question man
let's say so what immediately comes to
mind is what happens after
one dies
but
would you want to know the answer to
that
like there are some answers
that if it was the case
would you be willing to accept it big x
says knowing what you do now versus
prior to your first uip interviewee how
has your perspective changed and are you
worried for your children
firstly you don't have children i would
like i'm
i would like to have a child
i don't think i would be
no i i am worried but i think that's any
potential parents
that happens at every generation you're
worried about your kid
oh this is a great question underscore
asks has anyone showed you classified
things
no
i wish they
well i don't know if i wish they would
do you believe humans are being
monitored by aliens with super advanced
technology
i i see it being i see it's conceivable
that that's the case like if china can
potentially monitor
all of what's happening here and i'm
sure the us is monitoring china how's it
so out of the realm of possibilities
that someone far more advanced is doing
the same to us
though
though it may be the case that
as you're younger
as you're less wise you're more inclined
to look at someone's phone
let's say and snoop into someone's email
or read some sheet of paper you're not
supposed to
but as you i imagine
this is the case as one gets more quote
unquote wise
one is disinclined to do so because you
believe this is someone's private even
if there's information that is
that affects me
or reveals some lie of theirs that they
said to me and so on that's their
information that's their privacy
so it could be the case that with
the technological advancement assuming
aliens are more technologically advanced
then it may be the case that they have a
morality system such as that so perhaps
they could monitor us and choose not to
for some reason like that
kurt would you have alex jones on no i'm
not interested like maybe if i looked up
alex jones but i haven't looked
i haven't seen much about alex jones
other than
i i've seen that he looks like someone
who works out
extremely and is angry
but i don't know much about him so
i would i would potentially have on alex
jones but i don't know anything about
him
natalie says 7 20 17 29 it's making sure
that we place that into our working
memory spiritual astronaut are there
some areas related to the nature of
consciousness that you consider to be
too taboo
and perceived as shameful
too shameful to talk about seriously i
don't think so
not particularly and that's either
fortunately or unfortunately depending
on how one looks at it what is the
reason for you delving into these
conversations on physics consciousness
and free will says say in i am
i'm interested and i don't have a reason
outside of something that i would simply
confabulate to give you an answer
it's difficult to discern one's own
motivations
so i'm going to keep this to myself
until i've done enough
soul searching i find this topic
wonderfully pre-possessing i'll say that
for reasons outside my awareness
word counter reno cripperino i love that
name by the way i also try journaling
two in the morning so kurt if i may ask
do you open up a new
document and write on a blank slate each
morning or is it one large document
so just for some background i try to do
some writing each morning
just a few minutes
it's never an empty document
i have thoughts that occur to me
throughout the day and my skimble
scandal voice notes which i record
incessantly
that my wife hates because i interrupt
almost
whatever i interrupt whatever we're
doing like let's say we're watching a
movie i have to press pause or we're
going for a walk i have to in the middle
of a conversation
note to self so and so and so so i have
these short notes that i need to expand
upon later and i
generally
take those
incoherent ramblings and then enlarge
them i have themed docs and i place them
in their proper place
tadija mitrovic wants to know was there
a moment in the langan interview that
something clicked
where the where you had an understanding
of some concept that you had struggled
with before i believe it happened twice
during that interview but i don't
remember
i don't remember what it was
rad jre says if kurt is so smart why
doesn't he ask glaringly obvious
follow-ups he does have a velvety voice
though well thank you rad i'm not
terribly bright
and i'm unsure what follow-ups you're
referring to
see much of the time
what someone thinks is obvious is not
obvious to me and vice versa and also
there are quite a few
plates that are being spun
simultaneously whenever i'm speaking to
someone
so choosing exactly what question to ask
next is not a trivial task so for
example i'm thinking well what would the
person say to this and if i can predict
it i generally don't ask it if i can
predict what the person is going to say
even if it's interesting
well if it's sufficiently interesting
i'll ask it but if it's insufficiently
interesting i'm not going to ask it and
most of the time before the interview i
can heavily emulate the person in my
head for example with leo gura before we
started speaking i told him
i understand your theory at an
intellectual level
if someone i could
but this is presumptuous of me but if
someone was to ask leo gura a question i
could answer it and people wouldn't be
able to tell the difference that's what
i mean that i can emulate so i try to
get to the point where i can emulate the
person that's how i know that i have an
intellectual understanding it doesn't
mean that i have an embodied
understanding because well
that's completely different
so if i can predict what the person's
going to say i tend to not ask it
i'm also thinking of the other questions
that i have because i only have a
certain amount of time with the person
i'm also thinking about where is the
audience right now though i do so
minimally because
i tend to be selfish and think about
as if it's a one-on-one that's still
though in my mind where's the audience
in terms of the progression of what
we've talked about so far
i'm also thinking of the person that i'm
interviewing
stamina
how long they can how long they'll take
to answer the question
how they will take the question that is
how they will interpret the question
i watch their body language i see
if i'm pushing in a direction that will
loosen them or tighten them or
invigorate them or be less receptive to
follow-ups in this area but it's also
like chess where i can see or try to see
a couple moves ahead
so if i was to ask this this would lead
to this this would lead to this
so perhaps a better avenue is this so
that's also what's going on in my head
i'm also relating it like this is mainly
what's happening too is i'm relating
relating it to concepts i already
understand contextualizing it
so all of that's occurring
simultaneously and when you say that i
don't ask glaringly obvious follow-ups
i'm doing
well perhaps i'm not and that's those
are some of the reasons
i have a feeling what's underneath this
person's question is that i'm not being
skeptical enough but like i said my job
i don't see myself as being skeptical
i'm not there to critique them i'm there
to try to understand them plenty of
people they'll say hey you weren't tough
enough on louis ellison or tough enough
on so and so i invariably ask what do
you mean like what would be a question
that
i should have asked that i didn't and
they're almost
always questions about how do i know
what the person is saying is true
well
like i said i go in
assuming the person is truthful and then
thinking what are the consequences and
how do i relate it to other concepts
that i know how can i understand this
for example i
feel like leo guru is truthful when he
says that he believes he is whatever he
says he is and then i'm curious okay if
you believe that do you not also believe
this and so on and so on i'm not gonna
say no you're just saying that because
you want money
someone else can do that
hi yui says i'm interested
no this one's a bit
personal
well
in one of my videos i said i think the
leo gura video in the description
not in the video itself in the
description i said that i
want to thank jess palmer jess palmer is
someone who
let's see
i wrote an old friend who i realized
more and more was right about spiritual
matters despite my regretful obstinance
and derision
what i mean is that i had a
close friend named just
named jess and we would talk about
philosophy and i was so pig-headed
and
rude this is another reason why i say
that doesn't matter if you win
quote-unquote win an argument doesn't
mean you're right
because sometimes
someone can be right and not
be articulate enough to express that
they're right or say it in a manner that
well
anyway i would unconsciously view each
of our
interactions as a sparring battle and i
would just try to prove him wrong rather
than
get to quote unquote the truth
and it took me an inordinately long time
to realize i was doing that and it was
hurtful to him extremely hurtful damaged
it
was damaging to him
and i realized more and more now that
actually he was right in so many ways so
many ways
and i just regret that i treated him
like that some of to has it's positively
influenced toe in the sense that i take
that attitude this attitude of you know
maybe what this person is saying is
correct and they're just not saying it
correctly so can i add to it can i
approach it from a different angle not
to critique it not to destroy it but to
perhaps create with it
so this is
i have plenty of
plenty to thank
jess for and plenty to apologize to him
for
kevin kregan says kurt i wanted to ask
you about your statement that you had
noticed the various individuals in the
non-dualist spiritual school
as well as other teachers like thomas
campbell had impressed you as being more
or less phony
well i don't think i said that thomas
campbell was phony and if i did i take
that back
i don't think of him as phony
in fact i think the way thomas campbell
thinks and the way that i think are so
alike that it's almost like watching
myself
for example he was speaking to rupert
spyra
in some video
last month or two months ago it was like
watching myself speak to rupert spyra in
what he was putting up against rupert
spyro for example he was saying how do
you know there's some there's not
something outside consciousness well tom
is that not an unscientific question
yes well it
but how do you know well tom why would
you have to assume in the materialist
paradigm so the way that tom and spyro
were speaking with one another just the
way that i was speaking to spyra
kevin if you can find where i said that
i believe thomas campbell to be phony
then please
send that to me and
perhaps the context will reveal what i
meant or i simply misspoke or i was
simply wrong
so lord tyroness wants to know what's my
favorite theory of everything so far to
be honest it's usually the theory that
i'm
that i'm currently studying that's
usually my favorite and so that's a
secret right now
dirt flyer wants to know if i can get
bob lazar on the show i'm trying to get
bob lazar in the show as for what i
would like to ask him most it would be
some technical physics questions about
the strong force and gravity
phil parker says thank you so much for
being open-minded and not sticking to a
narrative and asking good questions
thanks phil i am not particularly
open-minded i know people say that
constantly i would just say that i
i'm foolish i'm too foolish to have a
world view and thus i don't know what's
true and so
i'm naive rather than open-minded
emma emma says have you heard of robert
lanza's theory of biocentrism
that consciousness creates reality well
i've heard of many theories that say
consciousness creates reality as for
robert lanza he's on the list i don't
think i've emailed him though i may have
natalie says
balaji
again balaji is bringing poor people
like me from all over the world on board
to be the change we all need in the
world he's an angel investor
i feel so lucky to be a part of the
changing world
i am a quadriplegic 39 year old dropped
at a sixth grade
all right
people if you would like
i'll leave natalie please leave a link
to
or dm me on twitter i don't think you
can leave links here dm me on twitter
and i'll leave a link to this person's
work in the description
zika foose if the uap is not government
could it be a private entity it could be
there's so almost any sentence that you
place after could it be is yes it's true
it could be so i don't know how to
answer a question like that and i also
don't know how to answer a question like
do i find it likely i don't i don't like
questions about probability i think the
way that people use it is more
indicative of unconscious beliefs than
it is of something like bayesian
reasoning
basically reasoning encompasses
unconscious beliefs anyway
because of priors or at leo
58246593 says i'm biased how do you
think your audience will react to leo
that is leo gura this was before the leo
video was posted
now again i don't like to think in terms
of my audience quote unquote
for one they're not watching me they're
not watching from
kurt necessarily they're watching
because they're interested in hearing
some
perspectives
perhaps they're watching because they
want to build their own toes so rather
than curt followers they're more like
toe builders additionally it's not like
i'm the host of toe like i am
well i'm the host of toe visually but
the movement of toe that is
whatever this is is
is larger than curt
and at some point i'll likely remove my
name from the channel because of that
i understand your question though
you're wondering okay how will people
who regularly view the toe channel view
leo gura
i think much in the same way that they
view bernardo castro or spyra though
more on the spyro side see it's
difficult for me to assess ontological
claims that allow for contradictions
because well the way that my mind works
is that you validate something usually
by proof
or invalidate
via proof
by contradiction and then when you're
not allowed that when someone says well
contradictions are allowed then firstly
anything that i say could be true and
untrue simultaneously
and secondly then you're left with proof
by construction
which is a terribly difficult act
terribly terribly difficult
hmm
pbr street gang says kurt jeremy said
that crap can go faster than the speed
of light and you didn't challenge him
why didn't you so again my
i'm not there to challenge
i also like i mentioned before sometimes
the meaning behind what someone is
saying is true the explication of it is
false
so
and thirdly who knows if we can exceed
the speed of light sure that will break
causality but it's not as if we think
that the mainstream view in physics
is that causality doesn't exist anyway
see people like sean carroll and there
are different models like steven
wolframs where there are different
speeds of light or more precisely that
one can exceed the speed of light
mozilla says man give yourself a break
in all caps literally and at all
different levels of analysis
simultaneously lol capitalized you need
capitalized that and deserve
that
being obsessed with productivity is
counterproductive even god himself had
at least a nap or something
yeah yes yeah well firstly i'm not
obsessed with pro with productivity at
all
well not at all but i'm not obsessed
with that
and i do need a break and i am going to
take a break
and just so you know for those
who are interested
there's two sources that allow me to do
this full-time and that is the patrons
and the sponsors
and if you would like to become a patron
and donate just to support this endeavor
slash support me
then you can go to patreon dot com slash
kurt jymungle i'll leave a link to that
it may seem like each dollar like a
dollar donation doesn't help a dollar
donation helps tremendously firstly
just
it's a vote of confidence
and
well
i'll leave it at that
and as for sponsors
there is algo so amjad hussein is a huge
supporter of the podcast a huge
supporter and has been since
almost its inception
i'll leave a link to amjad's podcast amd
has a podcast called algo about
artificial intelligence and
consciousness
he has a supply chain ai company i
recommend you at least visit amjad's
channel by subscribing to his channel
you're actually supporting this podcast
since one of his goals is to exceed a
certain amount of subscribers that helps
him with becoming a thought leader in
his space it helps his company it helps
this because it helps
him continue to support me so if you
like please and i'll do so right now
search for this
go to here and subscribe to amjad
chris leto wants to know what are your
top theories for uaps also i would love
to have you on my show anytime email me
on my youtube about page thanks either
way chris it'd be best if you email me
if you don't mind and i say the same
sentiment to you my email is on the
about page
as for my top theories of uaps i don't
have top theories
i'm such a
poor person to interview and by the way
tomorrow i have three interviews back to
back me being interviewed
on garrett vandenberg i also have a
podcast on the simulation podcast coming
up i think that's live
that's a ufo podcast and then i have
u-t-o-k greg henriques universal theory
of knowledge podcast
i hope i hope everyone i hope that i can
get enough sleep tonight so that i can
perform well on them that's what i i'm
worried about i hope i can get enough
sleep
most of my answers are just going to be
i don't know i don't know
to you chris
and to most of those people tomorrow
zika foose 2020 says on your show uap
has either
been government or aliens but no
discussion of private entity that's
false
richard dolan is a huge proponent of a
breakaway civilization which is
essentially a private entity
danger 6 says
have you considered that these beings
could be the solution to the fermi
paradox
no i know i haven't i don't like these
fermi paradoxes
or
drake equations and so on drawing
conclusions from them because there's so
many variables with so many unknowns
like so many well
so much uncertainty in so many variables
eric rogers take it easy doesn't mean
relaxing by the fireplace with hawking's
brief history of time
some of your followers may be curious as
to how you end up decompressing and
relaxing
see
well
i love to play video games so i'm very
much looking forward to taking some time
off and just playing some video games
hanging out with my wife eating like mad
that's what i my favorite activity is
eating whatever i like with my wife and
just sitting
in toronto walking around biking i love
that
i'll hopefully get to do some of that
over november and december
thomas martin why do you think you're so
hard on yourself so critical of your own
work
i don't feel like i'm hard on myself i
may be too easy on myself
zack meter says
would love to see a video dedicated to
how you research toes and your overall
process to researching theories of
everything i maybe one day it's not
terribly interesting essentially i look
up what other interviews the person has
done i look up the textbooks they've
written the popular books i've re i try
to read those
i
see if i can emulate them in my head i
see what questions arise i note them
down
and i look up the papers if they're
academics and that's pretty much
it i don't think i'm leaving anything
out
it's not terribly exciting
lock cockburn says do you think that a
theory of everything has to be believed
to be valid or can it just be sufficient
enough for the person
psychologically and it doesn't need to
involve complicated physics or social
theory
i'm guessing i'm asking is it personal
and if so can it be valid
and if not how can it be validated well
if i'm interpreting your question
correctly
it may have to be lived in some sense so
look we think of the theory of
everything as being some statement that
is either true and or is true
independent of humans and it may be it
may be more of a process than uh like
it's all huge speculation it may be a
process rather than a fact what i mean
by that is
some people think that wouldn't it be
boring to find a theory of everything
wouldn't your channel be done if you
found the toe
well firstly like you man it's hubris in
me thinking that we can
we can come close to finding the actual
toe but i'm still trying to push the
ball forward regardless but let's
imagine that there is an end
point it may not be a fact
it may be a process something like live
honorably or love people or act
sincerely and truthfully and if it's
that well then
time
steps forward progressively and so
that's something that we can always do
and it will always be with us
as long as we're in this temporal domain
it may be
a fact like that
this depends on if productionism is
correct but it may be that all of
physics comes from something like that i
don't know what that could possibly mean
i'm
just this is all suppositious
but it could be that the ultimate law is
a process
now there is some reason to think so at
least biblically
religiously god has been described as i
am
what comes into being like i am a
process i am becoming itself
and god is synonymous with reality in
many respects
so it's not so far off it's not so out
there
what if the ultimate answer was be
loving and bring joy to others
that's a process
and that has to be lived
jim
allen wants to know about why didn't i
like rupert spyro's king lear analogy
i've he says i've always found this to
be a useful analogy so i want to know
what you find problematic about it so i
don't recall exactly
what it is that i disliked about it if i
remember it correctly it was something
like rupert spyro was saying that
the actor forgets that they were
some i they actor forgets their former
identity and assumes the role
that's called method acting technically
so it's like we method acted our way
here however there's an element of
repetition and conscious effort for the
method actor one is conscious at first
that they're not king lear and then
assumes king lear's identity
and that doesn't seem to comport with
what rupert is saying in other respects
that is unlike with king lear one has a
prior conception prior to hitting this
stage
doug tar nepal must there be a theory of
everything i'm not so sure
well there must there doesn't
necessarily have to be it seems like
there are regularities as far as we can
tell we call them the laws of physics
they describe the universe more and more
and more with each passing decade and
it's unclear if it approaches some limit
david ortega says
when you say comparing any two items
there's manifold ways in which they're
similar and dissimilar can you better
explain that i really like the podcast
thank you david what i mean is that you
can endlessly enumerate the properties
of let's say this cup and you can also
create new properties so what's the
difference between this cup and another
cup that's on my table well they have
different volumes but they have the same
color they were both drank from by
so-and-so person so that's a commonality
but they did not touch the mouth of
someone so other person
they were made within one year of one
another that's a commonality it's also a
difference if you want to get more
refined and say one was made on october
27th and another was made on august 3rd
you can keep
listing properties and find similarities
and dissimilarities that's another
reason why any political discourse for
me is so vastly complicated because most
of the time people will say
look at what's happened in the past and
that's what's going to happen in the
future so let's say look at what's
happened under capitalistic germany or
fascist germany or communist china and
so on or communist russia and so on
firstly then you would have to say
whether or not it is capitalism or it is
socialism and there are many properties
there it's not as if
there's agreement on what constitutes
capitalism and socialism and so on or
which countries obey socialism or which
countries obey capitalism then you can
always say that yes
socialism of the past or a country that
promo country that held the banner of
socialism
had so and so disastrous outcome but
it doesn't apply to now because of these
properties that are different there are
always properties that are different and
properties that are the same so one can
always make the case that the past
doesn't apply to the future or it does
these are such complicated issues people
want to say that it's all
one side is correct over another i tend
to
believe in this
quote by arthur cain
who said
only the shallowests of mine believe
only the shallowest of minds believe
that in great controversy one side is
mere folly okay so matthew kappazoli
says i do a show about theoretical
physics exploring free will
consciousness and the journey to the
theory of everything firstly matthew my
lawyers are going to contact you
secondly given your unparalleled career
at the forefront of modern academia i'm
not at the forefront nor am i in modern
academia and scholarship albeit mainly
in tangential fields what are some
insights
you may think are helpful for anyone
researching these topics i would say
don't reiterate what you've heard and
pretend to know it like i mentioned
you'll hear invective against string
theory being unfalsifiable affirmed
merely by mathematical beauty but you
don't know that
it takes years to understand what that
means
do you know the polyakov action so
that's a fundamental equation in string
theory you don't even know that or not
you as i mean one doesn't even know that
i'm not trying to accuse you of anything
matthew in other words stop
intellectually posturing it's a form of
lying stop lying and see how far you'll
get that's my advice matthew
monkey
hq says i wish i was here my wish is
when you make a q a the first question
asked to you will be
how did this channel emerge with such
quality
that it redefined standards of youtubers
to show the full potential of youtube
now
there's a
wonderfully complimentary question
it didn't start off firstly it doesn't
redefine anything secondly it didn't
start off with quality it started off
with better left unsaids interviews that
i just posted from my documentary those
were horrible horrible horrible me
interjecting constantly trying to be a
thought leader of some sort if i'm being
honest egotism insincerity and
insecurity
is how the channel started off
and that's a quality that's only been
tempered
rather than
expirated chris smith says
question for you kurt
when you ask yourself a question how do
you know when you found the answer when
are you satisfied enough to stop
searching well firstly you don't know
when you found the answer you know when
you think you found the answer and
that's different it's like um
it's
almost every fact is like a mystery
novel and we've seen like the thomas
kuhn has a whole book on this paradigms
keep changing recontextualizing what we
think of as true and so on one of the
reasons that
mystery novels are fascinating as
they're expressing this fact to us that
we think we know and then we don't know
so for example you think you found the
murder weapon
and it turns so you think you found the
gun it's a murder weapon turns out it's
a prop in a play okay it turns out then
that the person didn't end up dying from
a gunshot they ended up dying from a
from a knife wound and then you find out
oh actually what we thought was a knife
wound was
not inflicted by someone else the killer
was the person it was suicide and then
you realize oh the person wasn't dead at
all they faked it this happens over and
over
i have a word for this well it's not my
word but it's a word that i
use it's called enthymeme so
e-n-t-h-y-m-e-m-e
and those are conclusions that we've
drawn where
the
premises or some of them are unstated
and almost every single fact is like
that there are an incessant
proliferation of
assumptions that go into
almost any conclusion and we don't
realize we're making them
and they're so so subtle
okay getting back to the chat
there are quite a few questions here
kurt what do i think of nietzsche i
don't know nietzsche's was contradictory
and you don't have
nietzsche
alive to ask him this i don't
particularly like when people make
appeal to
dead philosophers for example with
einstein people say look einstein said
the block universe time is illusory
firstly einstein said that once in a
letter to console a friend it wasn't a
physics letter
and einstein was someone who changed his
mind many times in his life you can't
ask him what did you mean by that do you
mean illusory in which sense there are
many senses of the word effin m says
sorry for such a bland question but i'm
wondering what are your thoughts at this
point about the mind-body consciousness
problem so that's not a bland question
there's a whole field like if many
papers
and fields of science are the cognitive
science are
predicated on that question i don't know
i'm still thinking about it
john griffin
do you worry that your decision to
provide a platform for unorthodox
subject matter could have a negative
impact on a vulnerable uncritical
audience
that can be said about so much
and yes i worry about it but not much
i worry more about
what not
following my intuition and exposing
people to ideas that they thought were
asinine let's say or imbecilic
would do to the world there's so much
almost all the facts that we think of
now were unorthodox
that someone would have said
have a negative impact on a vulnerable
uncritical audience almost every single
fact right now that we think of
riat seal says love the sincerity
imbibed in your work kurt definition
rudely brief
please interview sad guru i've i've
contacted saad guru and he is
uninterested in being interviewed or at
least as people are
rat reacts
reatsile asks again
well
he says please also investigate e8 i
will i'll talk to
garrett lisi
and clee irwin in 2022
leon wants to know what do i think of
the buddhist view of the universe i'm
going to be exploring eastern traditions
more in 2022
alexander stone have i spoken with or
researched richard dodie i think i
researched him quite some time ago
briefly when i was preparing for the
jeremy corbell interview the first one
but
i i don't remember much about him
bastian ray says are you a mystical or a
physicalist i think he means
i think he means idealist or physicalist
i think sometimes your contents slash
guests are contradictory and extremely
confusing like having sabine hosenfelder
and thomas campbell with totally
opposite views i think
most of these contents are more
confusing with so many opposing concepts
over and over that it seems like the
tower of babel
hmm
right well my question is why would you
want just one type of viewpoint you can
have that just read one source i don't
know how one would
how would one determine which view is
correct without exploring the
alternatives
it would be like it like more extremely
mundane example is as if you've only
eaten
cherries and you think that's the best
not only fruit but food
there's a contradiction between cherries
and apples and
hamburgers and macaroni and cheese so
why are you exploring macaroni and
cheese and cherries well
i'm interested in food perhaps they're
not opposite perhaps they're combined in
some manner perhaps
you can't compare them in the same way
that you can compare numbers
they're okay just so you know in
mathematics not everything is comparable
there's a whole just partially ordered
sets it's something you learn in first
year mathematics a partially ordered set
can't always compare two elements of a
set
you have to define an order i understand
that it's difficult to follow some of
the podcasts because of the wide ranging
views but that just means that one needs
to put some more effort into it rather
than it being a conceptual flaw
the channel assumes a level of
high effort and trust on those people
watching
sicily says if you had the chance to
make a closer to truth interview with
great thinkers or scientists of the past
who have already passed away who would
you pick
hillary putnam
raymond smallian
and
and there's someone named
someone i don't know i never researched
but some people keep saying i should
research ramada maharshi is someone that
i would
interview but i don't know so that's
just that's just a guess on my part
hillary putnam raymond smallian and
romana
okay
well i'll do a couple more chat
questions and then i should get going
kurt iphone or android android all the
way man
samuel
lorenzo says what do you think of
box statement that only a simulation can
be conscious see i don't
he's saying yeah
samuel is saying i don't understand that
consciousness arises from feedback loops
and self-representation i don't either
and i also see that as
self-consciousness rather than
consciousness per se so douglas
hofstra's book is more to me
a book about self-consciousness rather
than consciousness but
obviously hofstetter and bach are
extremely extremely bright people and so
that means to me that i'm not
understanding their theories correctly
i just we act says have i tried to speak
to the highly overrated jordan peterson
i wouldn't say he's overrated in the
least i mean it depends on which camp in
many ways he's underrated by a certain
subset of people
overrated by some yeah but i wouldn't
say as a whole he's overrated
and i will speak to him at some point
and what make or model is the chair that
i'm sitting on i don't know i'll look
that up
by the way again speaking of sponsors
amjad hussein
the reason that i'm able to sit in this
chair rather than the one that you see
in some older videos is because of amjad
amjad said kurt what can make your life
easier as a podcaster so i said
firstly thank you so much amjad and what
it would be would be a standing desk so
this is now a standing desk
some
a chair and a couple other
pieces of equipment and namjod said i'm
going to support you man so amjad thank
you and you can visit
this link which i will send you again to
subscribe to amjad
because subscribing to hamjad is like
supporting this podcast if you can't
give
a dollar to this podcast or don't want
to for whatever reason
support amjad because that supports this
podcast indirectly
you can subscribe tomjad at that link
stephen stergle wants to know how can
you be
conscious without self-consciousness
well
does a baby have any form of self are
you willing to torture a baby that's
what i would say to that tw says looking
forward to watching it tomorrow in the
singularity lab keep up the good the
great work good work thank you so the
chair that i have is called ergo 3d
ergonomic office chair by n-o-u-h-a-u-s
it also has these roller blades for
wheels instead of the traditional wheels
so i can move around and it doesn't make
noise
tdr says thanks for
getting
me through my boring job yes
they can help out with that the podcasts
certainly have that effect
james spice what's your take on
sasquatch
i don't think it's out of
the realm of possibilities that it's an
actual creature jane goodall who's a
primatologist thinks that may be the
case and that perhaps sasquatch should
be considered a protected species
steven stergle so i don't understand
your question if you say that i reversed
it
if you don't mind rewriting it
differently please grillous investors
gribulus
if i'm pronouncing that correctly says
is solipsism a common trap dead end
hmm i think that if you're a solopsist
then you shouldn't believe that your
consciousness ends when you die
and the reason is that
you have no evidence of other conscious
beings ending
because if you think you're the only
conscious being then anything that you
see that potentially dies quote unquote
didn't die they had no consciousness to
begin with you have no evidence that
your consciousness ceases
so i'd say it's strange to me that a
solipsist would ever say that
consciousness ends when the physical
body dies they have zero evidence of it
jack burden what video game am i most
looking forward to now these are the
real questions man
i'm looking forward to
alden ring
though the graphics on that are horrible
and no one on the elden ring subreddit
wants to say that they start criticizing
anyone who says that
and they'll say people don't play games
for graphics firstly bloodborne was
wonderful for me partially because of
the graphics oh my gosh when that came
out that is
beautiful graphics bloodborne and that
increased the
my experience of it so when people say
that graphics don't matter well then you
play on a computer that has the ability
to increase the graphics and
purposefully downgrade the graphics
and don't have the concomitant fps boost
and see do you like that no you actually
prefer the graphics to be as great as
they can be
okay so alvin ring either way no matter
what yes the gameplay matters most and
i'm very much looking forward to that
regardless of how it looks i trust from
software
i wish that they would remake or
remaster red dead or released gta 6 that
i would very much be looking forward to
the genres of video games i like open
world games and
i love fallout games
favorite movie i covered earlier
no i don't like vr i've tried it
and jonathan blow says that right now
it's a gimmick i tend to agree
pg is asking have i considered esoteric
topics like mediumship
i don't know what that i've never heard
of that so i haven't considered it i am
going to be
interviewing dean raiden at some point
yeah magic turtle interview you asked me
should i interview annika harris i've
reached out to annika harris haven't
heard a reply
and i believe i've done so more than
once
there were also a couple questions asked
afterward on twitter and i'll answer
them now
fakery
fakery official that is says do you feel
art theory improves appreciation of art
for you personally including music film
painting culinary games etc how do you
how did you learn film techniques
so i watched a menagerie of youtube
videos of all sorts ranging from after
effects tutorials to sound mixing and
then i analyzed them fairly
punctiliously with a pen and paper i
took one theory class to its completion
that is a film theory class and it
showed me what film form was and how one
can scrutinize art in a much less
subjective manner disconnected from the
story which is the opposite of what most
filmmakers are taught they're taught
it's all about the story and it's not as
for if art improves or art theory
improves my appreciation the answer is
yes for me
as
i have a difficult time appreciating
what i don't know
if i don't know how something was
created i
appreciate it much less or
to be more accurate once i know how
something's created i can appreciate it
more for example i know how rock music
is created because i was in a band at
some point and so i appreciate rock
music but i can't appreciate modern
music
to the same degree i don't know how it
is they make the beats that they make i
don't know how they apply the effects i
also don't see why modern songs
are in the mainstream credited to the
singer rather than the producer because
i see the
end result as being 90 the producer
rather than the singer the singers like
the whipped cream
but i also imagine that's much
the same phenomenon as people liking the
actors or knowing that an actor is in a
film and wanting to see a film because
of that rather than the writer slash
director
when i watch movies my eyes dart around
the screen extremely sporadically rarely
paying attention to the story because i
know a bit about how movies are created
i'm often thinking about why they made
certain choices and not other choices
steve pigott at gorilla dolphin asks i'd
enjoy hearing you ruminate on what it's
like
to feel like someone is making sense but
you still don't understand them there is
an amphibological quality to most
statements on consciousness and
metaphysics in general luckily i'm fine
with the ambiguity and i would say that
a skill of mine if one can call it that
is to be comfortable with ideas that
don't cohere there's an intuition i may
feel of connection when someone says
something explicitly then i look at what
it means implicitly unconsciously and
then i see that it's consonant with some
established concept of mine this is all
unconscious so what i'm saying may not
be entirely accurate as it's difficult
to know what's going on unconsciously
i'm telling you how i feel my
intimations and this occurs when
someone's speaking so to me that's
illustrative of them making sense
implicitly at one level but then not
explicitly on another level let's say
the surface level
jeff said you have a phenomenal
vocabulary okay so this is a point of
contention for some people some people
quite
like the
level of technicality in the videos and
some people dislike them now one has to
be careful not to use words to sound
more intelligent as it often has the
opposite effect i also feel like some
words that are small to other people are
in fact large to me or new to me at
least and vice versa
when i'm speaking with someone i often
use it as an exercise
so that is when you go to the gym you
have
improper form at first but then you
exercise and that's how you build the
muscle when i was about 22 or 20 yeah
when i was about 22 i came to this
conclusion that i'm not going to use
words that i think that the other person
may not know in person i'm not going to
going to use that when i'm walking and
talking with someone
because it makes them it can make
someone and even me it can make me feel
obtuse or inane because it's not fun
when you have to ask someone what's the
definition of a word so i made it a
policy when i was younger that if it's
with text or video or some place where
people can pause and not feel publicly
the cerebrate let's say well then i can
say it for example in it in this form
it's also a bit unfair
because when i write alone i i write in
this manner in the manner that i speak
when i think i think with these words i
also feel like words are batons when i
say fatans i take this concept from
douglas hofstetter
words are like
cognitive tools they make your cognition
more flexible
one way that you can see this is that if
i was to ask you would you like me to
remove
100 of your words at random you would
probably not like that the reason is
those words help you access other points
that you couldn't access before and the
amount that you could express would be
so diminished the amount that you can
think would be so diminished as well now
just take it to the opposite where you
want to add words and the more words
that you add it's like adding extra
tools to your toolbox you can do more
with them you can think more rapidly
and make connections that you weren't
able to before as soon as you can give a
name to a concept you can all of a
sudden use that concept whereas before
it was 10 concepts now it's just one
it's also the case that it's going to
sound awkward and this is going to be
the case for anyone who's trying to
let's say one is trying to lose weight
in a group of friends who is who are
overweight you're all overweight you're
going to get made fun of
because people don't particularly like
when one person is improving in some
manner they'll call you disingenuous and
question your motivations the only way
for me to improve my linguistic
cognition would be for me to continually
use the words
and with
repetition comes the facility with them
so for example there's a guitar behind
me
if you play the f chord initially it's
going to mute most of the strings
but then that's not a reason to not play
the f chord you just have to keep
playing it until you get it correct and
then all of a sudden the amount of music
that you can create is vast there are so
many
myths about vocabulary like people will
say don't use a five dollar word when a
one dollar one will do and feynman was
great at speaking simply feynman wasn't
great at speaking simply he would speak
to a public to the public simply but if
he's speaking to scientists behind doors
this is from an abstract of one of his
papers the representation of fermi
particles by two component poly spinners
satisfying a second order differential
equation and the suggestion that in p
decay these spinners act without
gradient couplings lead to an
essentially unique weak for fermion
coupling it is equivalent to
so on and so on what about that is
simple
it sounds extremely verbose now you also
have to match your vocabulary to who
you're speaking to
for example when one speaks to a child
one speaks laconically and warmly and
then when one speaks to a ten-year-old
one speaks differently than when one
speaks to a 15 year old and so on and so
on and if i'm speaking to
some of the brightest minds on the
planet
it's like my
mind kicks in gear that's enough that
i'll say about that the next question
comes from alien lives matter
do you edit your ufo podcasts and if so
can you place a can you put up a
compilation of your edits
because there may be nuggets well i
don't edit any sentiments out of the
podcast mainly what i remove are my own
sprawling pauses and there may be times
where there's an audio or video glitch
and i'll try to edit a few frames around
it but it's never
it's never removing what someone was
trying to express
griswaldgrim says does the youtube
channel that is the tow channel need a
showrunner like a sitcom does is it like
being a captain of a ship for you so i
asked griz walt what he meant and he
said basically how many people does it
take to run the show
like if i was gone how many people would
it take to run it's just me i do
i do everything right now
for the toe clippings channel i do
outsource that but the
toe main channel that's all me from
contacting the people directly to speak
with them
to editing to compiling the questions to
the research to the follow-up and so on
all of that is
currently me
even responding to the comments right
now as myself and hopefully at some
point i can get my wife to take over
that as it's becoming a bit overwhelming
it's actually more than a bit
overwhelming to be quite frank
i've just had only
an hour or two hours or
or so of sleep
i was editing this video and then i got
these twitter comments and so i'm adding
these right now but it's quite
it's quite a bit of work and so that's
why again i keep mentioning this i'm
very much looking forward to taking some
months off i need to do that for my own
mental health
all right well
thank you everyone i should get going i
appreciate that you've
been here so long with me
do i think that we have yet to discover
more fundamental forces yes
yeah mima type s for linda moulton howe
yes i'm interviewing her i'm
interviewing diana posilka in 2022.
take care everyone thank you
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you